[Música]
en Francia 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en el capítulo anterior
hablábamos de cómo se vuelve cada vez
más imperativo ampliar el acceso a la
Inteligencia artificial para reducir las
brechas entre las sociedades y como
expertos del mundo y artistas piden
mayores regulaciones Pues ahora es el
llamado padrino de la Inteligencia
artificial Jeffrey Hilton quien alertó
que si bien en este momento las máquinas
no son más inteligentes que los humanos
sí podrían llegar a hacerlo lo que
supone un grave peligro para la
humanidad
pide que se mire lo que ocurría hace
cinco años y se compare con la
actualidad en cuestión de desarrollos es
Entonces cuando asegura que una
regulación es clave pero también ponerle
un freno a esta presión y competencia
entre compañías que puede ser sumamente
irresponsable a la hora de ganar
usuarios sin que haya un enfoque
responsable a corto plazo advierte de
tres peligrosos primero una creación de
contenido digital falsa hablamos de
fotos videos y textos que una persona
promedio será imposible comprobar lo que
es verdad segundo Aunque en el presente
la Inteligencia artificial ayuda y
complementa el trabajo de una persona
advierte que en futuro podría llegar a
reemplazar asistentes legales
traductores y otros oficios cotidianos y
tercero y aún más grave que versiones
futuras de esa tecnología podrían ser
una amenaza para la humanidad si las
personas y las empresas permiten que los
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial
además de generar códigos los ejecuten
lo que podría llevar a convertirlos en
armas autónomas Incluso en los llamados
robots asesinos veamos más de lo que
dijo y su relevancia en el informe es
una tecnología que podría ser superior
al cerebro humano y uno de sus Pioneros
dice ahora que una parte del Lamento
haber participado en su creación Jeffrey
Hilton informático de 75 años dice que
dejó su trabajo en Google Para poder
compartir de forma independiente sus
preocupaciones sobre la tecnología de
Inteligencia artificial
qué hacemos para mitigar los riesgos a
largo el caso de que cosas más
inteligentes que nosotros tomen el
control cosas como el chipity Four
eclipsan a una persona en la cantidad de
conocimiento generales que posee y la
eclipsan con creces en términos de
razonamiento no es tan bueno pero ya
hace razonamiento simples en marzo
después de que opina y lanzar el último
modelo su chatbot más de 1000 personas
del sector tecnológico entre ellas el
multimillonario elon musk y el
cofundador de Apple Steve firmaron una
carta pidiendo una moratoria en el
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
el jefe científico de Google respondió a
sus entrevistas en un comunicado
seguimos comprometidos con un enfoque
responsable de la Inteligencia
artificial aprendemos continuamente para
comprender los riesgos emergentes al
tiempo que innovamos con audacia el
propio Hilton afirmó que Google ha
actuado hasta ahora como un
administradora adecuado de la tecnología
pero que está sufriendo una presión cada
vez mayor por parte de la competencia
advierte que los gigantes tecnológicos
están atrapados en una carrera que
requerirá una regulación mundial para
frenarla dejamos atrás este tema y nos
vamos a París la capital francesa porque
en el aeropuerto de orley están probando
escáneres 3D para maletas de cabina una
tecnología que busca agilizar los
controles de seguridad sin sacrificar la
precisión lo que se logra con estos
aparatos es por ejemplo que las personas
ya no tengan que abrir sus maletas y
sacar los recipientes con líquidos o los
aparatos portátiles como computadores
algo que ahorra tiempo y esfuerzo
sí es revolucionario creo que esa es la
palabra no nos equivocamos porque
estamos avanzando hacia una relación
real con los pasajeros es un respiro
tanto para los pasajeros como para los
empleados de seguridad Cuando dicen
tengo un portátil tengo un teléfono les
decimos No señor ya no lo tiene que
sacar la gente no lo puede creer Y eso
significa establecer una relación más
fresca más ligera lo que nos permite
enfocarnos en la calidad del servicio
que siempre estamos buscando
otros terminales aéreos como hidrow en
Londres o She Paul en ámsterdam están
experimentando este sistema Pero el Dios
Lee en París cuenta con la versión más
reciente del Software que es más veloz
con las imágenes 3D la maleta se muestra
en segundos en la pantalla y el operador
puede girar la imagen para verla desde
todos los ángulos
seguimos en Europa Pero pasamos a España
para conocer este esqueleto de mamut
lanudo el animal más emblemático icónico
de La era de hielo los primeros de los
que se tiene registro aparecieron en
África pero en ese momento paseaban por
una región que hoy en día se extendería
desde Reino Unido y España hasta la
Siberia rusa que fue donde fueron
hallados estos restos que miden 6 metros
de largo por tres punto cinco metros de
alto
esta exposición es única por muchas
cosas pero sobre todo por la pieza
central que es sistema multa ludo un
mamut de que vivió en la Tierra hace
unos 50.000 años entre 45.000 y 50.000
años estuvo aquí entre nosotros y ha
estado enterrado hasta hace más o menos
cinco años hace cinco años estaba en una
remota zona de Siberia y donde unos
paleontólogos se lo encontraron y
nosotros tuvimos la oportunidad de
adquirirlo otro de los mayores
atractivos de la muestra es la colección
de muelas del Museo Nacional de ciencias
naturales y del instituto Catalán de
paleontología miquel Cruz a font los
científicos explican que se pueden
obtener muchísimas informaciones de los
dientes de cualquier especie y
puntualmente de los mamuts
hace 50 millones de años sus molares se
parecían más a los nuestros porque tenía
una dieta más parecida a lo que podemos
tener nosotros de frutas elementos tipo
corteza que son que son más duros sin
embargo con las glaciaciones con el frío
deja de empiezan a desaparecer los
grandes extensiones de bosques y ser
sobre todo praderas se cree que los
mamuts lanudos se extinguieron hace unos
Diez mil años aunque los científicos
creen que pequeños grupos de ellos
pueden haber vivido más tiempo en Alaska
y en la isla Ranger en Rusia frente a la
costa de Siberia así concluimos este
espacio quédense con nosotros que hay
más en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]